perhaps one of the most confusing
aspects around the new marvel's
adventures game is uh
what kind of game is it exactly like how
much of it is single player versus
multiplayer
how does the game's progression work and
is it really just destiny 2 with a
marvel skin on it
this can be rather unclear to the
average person if you haven't been
keeping up with developer live streams
we got early access to the game's beta
and we're finally starting to get a
clear picture
and yeah it's actually a lot like
destiny
let's get the biggest question out of
the way yes game does have a single
player campaign
as you play through the campaign you
unlock more of the game's content and
features like new mission types heroes
and multiplayer
hero missions are single player only and
these are where you're gonna get most of
the game story and cut scenes
in them you are given specific heroes to
play and do unique missions to continue
the game's main story
in the beta you play as hulk and kamala
khan
who enter a secret aim facility in
search of jarvis
the campaign is a purely single-player
experience and
at least in the beta the missions are
not repeatable
after the completion of a few hero
missions in the beta you go to the
chimera
an avengers helicarrier and the game's
social space
early on the chimera is mostly abandoned
with only bruce and kamala there and the
rest is all locked off
presumably the camaro will fill up with
more characters and functions as you
progress through the game's story
it's essentially the hub where you'll go
between missions
which leads us to the most important
part of the chimera the war table which
is how you pick your next objective and
access the multiplayer the war table is
broken up
by environmental zones that populate
with different mission types
the largest of these missions are called
war zones
these are multi-objective missions where
you move across several locations
for example this war zone in the pacific
northwest starts you out in an open
forest before eventually leading you
into a small
underground aim facility the missions
are fairly straightforward but there are
small opportunities to deviate off the
main path to find
chess beat up tough enemies or break
into depots for bonus
loot where war zones are meant to be
longer more involved missions for those
looking for something quick you have
drop zones these are bite-sized versions
of war zones with only a single
objective
and they take around 5 to 10 minutes to
complete war zones and drop zones are
meant to be repeatable with multiple
difficulties
you start to see a lot of repeating
environments and objective types so
don't expect these to be as handcrafted
as the campaign missions
that said you will get some more unique
war zones such as condition green where
you're recommended but not required to
play as the hulk
or ones with a boss fight at the end
there's one more mission type in the
beta and those are the
harm emissions these take place in a
combat simulation room
aboard the chimera and are wave based
combat challenges
war zones drop zones and harm missions
are all multiplayer focused with
options to match make or invite your
friends however you can play
everything single player if you want
bringing ai companions with you instead
these ai will use the gear and skills
you've acquired for them
so if you decide to play purely single
player you're going to want to maintain
levels of multiple heroes
there are three progression systems for
every hero
character level power level and
challenge card
character levels are the most
straightforward as their purpose is to
provide you with a new skill point for
each level
you then use these skill points to
unlock a new skill
power level is an indicator of your
stats every piece of gear has a power
level on it and the average of all of
them
is your power level if you've played
destiny then
it's exactly like that game's power
system
gear can also be boosted and with each
boost it increases the power level of
that gear
doing so requires using one of the game
several resources and which resource it
is
depends on the gear uncommon gear can be
boosted 3 times
rare gear 5 times and epic and legendary
gear
10 times equipment like epic gear will
have multiple perks on them
but you'll need to boost it in order to
unlock the perks
last are challenge cards which are
basically battle passes
they go all the way up to level 40 and
each level unlocks cosmetics like
outfits name plates and emotes
or some extra resources you earn points
towards your challenge card by
completing daily and weekly
challenges the challenge cards in the
beta don't offer any sort of paid option
with everything being labeled as
free but there is an empty space for
what is
likely a paid track and yes every hero
has their own individual challenge card
based on our time with the beta this
appears to be the core loop of marvel's
avengers
you have a single player campaign
intermixed with repeatable multiplayer
missions
with the chimera acting as your hub the
progression system seems designed to
keep you playing
long after the story is finished but
until we get our hands on the full
release it's hard to say what avengers
end game will look like if you don't
have access to the beta and want to know
how it actually felt to play the darn
thing
well go check out our impressions video
with jordan phil and myself
and for more on avengers stay tuned to
game spot
wow